well i was born in puerto rico um
dark skinned puerto rican
i have a lot of siblings that are
a range of colors
at
my birth i had
um brothers
two
two brothers older brothers reggie and
eddie and um
i never i seen pictures of us as kids
but i never knew or met them or had an
incident or remembering how to interact
with them
my parents
had known
family uh
a black family that married into our
family and um
they had all girls
and they wanted a son
and my mother um adopted me into
adopted me to them and i was the one boy
who grew up with three girls
um
came to california they moved to long
beach california
and
went through life a little different and
struggling
life was a little harder for me
[Music]
learning the language catching on to the
basicism of it i was a little different
but
i kind of adapted to it it was kind of
cool i met a lot of mexicans in long
beach um it was cool because they spoke
spanish and i did too so it's kind of
the connection was cool um
hung back and chilled
enjoyed life and adapted um had a few
friends and things like that and got
cool with the family and kind of
interacted to it got into southern food
pig feeding cornbread and collard greens
and loved it and it was a change from
the
um carne asada burritos and stuff like
that that happened that i grew up with
but you know life is what it is
um
my mother and father my adopted parents
my mother effie my father charles
had their struggles life was a little
funny they were
in and out of issues with themselves but
my mom was so protective of us that she
did everything to keep sure to make sure
that we were cool
[Music]
we could discipline like everybody else
did if we messed up
in our family
usually if one of us got in trouble we
all kind of got punished for it and our
parents started remembering different
things like that that happened
um so we all were nervous when one of us
got in trouble because we knew kind of
whatever we did wrong that we catch an
[ __ ] for it
it's kind of unique but hey you know
life is what it is um i love my mom to
death she was my best friend favorite
friend
she was always there for me when things
went wrong
when things got bad
um
she was my protector she was my shield
fell in love with my sisters my sisters
also in my family
my name is tywin
but everybody calls me tai
um
and all of us are ortiz so my sisters
are my oldest sister is tara my second
sister is tina and my younger sister is
tabitha so all of us grew up in a funny
relationship of having teased you know
and it was cool life was perfect i loved
my sisters to death
my sister taro was a little thug one
tina was a super intelligent one and dad
was a while like me
um things were crazy me and tapping were
real close
um
i actually didn't get closer to my
sister tina until after i got older
[Music]
tara scared all of us because she had
this you know mentality that
things were
have to be run by her and the
controlling faction i loved her to death
now that we're older i love my sisters
to death and
i'll do any and everything for their
approval
um
but as life progressed and things went
on um i had
um an uncle
and cousins
who would come to the house and visit
and relax and
would go in the garage and build stuff
with my dad who did a lot of
construction and stuff like that
and they would come over and chill and
you know things would happen and
life would progress
well little did i know that um growing
up i was molested by
my uncle buck
and my cousin elton
and this happened for years from the age
of nine
to maybe
15 or 16.
um
i
told my dad about it once
and
nervous actually telling him about it
and um
he didn't believe me um
told me to stop lying
and then if i lied again that you know
he would whip me
and
make sure i didn't go out or hang out
and chill or he wouldn't take me out or
do things
um
my dad was
in his own little world he was a
minister for a church
and everybody loved him
um
he was you know
the fan favorite for everybody
but um my dad abused my mom he beat my
mom relentlessly
and he would beat us
and
everybody loved him in church and
took care of him and everything was done
well he lived one life on the streets
and the church and then another one at
home with us
my dad would take me to sea world and
the zoo and hang back and chill chilling
kind of spoiling me with things
to keep his secret why he would
have relationships with other girls and
he would take out and enjoy with him and
hey make him chill so i always saw my
dad um
being with different girls and
one in particular that he
ended up
[Music]
divorcing my mom to marry
and
[Music]
it was
really hard
[Music]
i was always nervous to say anything
because i figured if i ever told him my
dad then he would stop taking me out and
buying things for me and stuff like that
so he kind of bought my silence
and um
i kind of ran into life like that well
during the time of that happening
my uncles would come over and my cousin
would come over and they would molest me
for years actually
and
i happened at first and it freaked me
out
and um
it was nerve-wracking actually um
after years of it happening and nobody
believing
i got used to it i got accustomed to the
lifestyle
um
from being raped annually
um for years
i grew up and realized i was a lot um
more blessed in the front
and well i had a you know great ass and
everything and
everything but i had a huge penis and
people usually liked it
so i grew up in the neighborhood and
would always walk around in shorts
playing basketball and stuff like that
and
certain people in the neighborhood would
start picking up on it and
i started hooking up with different guys
and
in the neighborhood
and
we kept a huge big secret and try to
never tell anybody about it
um
there was one person in particular uh a
guy named damar i loved him to death and
him and i he was a latin black and latin
guy
and um i skinned it and him and i
chilled and for years together
and
there was also two twins that lived
maybe five houses down the block from us
matt and brian
and for years like all of us
messed around with each other
and i had to keep a big superhero for my
sisters and brothers and for my sisters
and my mom and parents
so i
lived a perfectly straight life normally
even though undercoverly i was you know
sexually active with all the guys in the
neighborhood
then to keep the coverants i got a
girlfriend's
um
sparkle
and um
susan who lived in the neighborhood
and
became sexually active with them and
realized because of my experience with
the guys that i was with
that i was really good at being um
enticing enough to to gain approval from
whether it was a guy or a girl
and
they fell in love with me and
me never wanting to ever see
what happened to me happened to anybody
else i became real recursive you know
we're blocking the people are getting
nearly if i saw any abuse or anything
happening around
because of what i saw from my dad doing
to my mom
my adopted parents um
i pushed away from them so if i see
somebody being physical or
somebody snapping at a girl or something
like that i was really protected to jump
up for somebody
because of the raping that was still
happening um off and on um
i needed protection
and my family my adoptive family were
all like crips in the neighborhood in
the neighborhood and i didn't get along
with them um so i joined a hispanic gang
um
and um became an active gang member
and lived the lifestyle and tried to
keep it away from my family without them
ever knowing but i was learning how to
fight and i was really really good at it
and um
got back together and
got to feel my homework from the
neighborhood and decided we were going
to
get together and um
attempt to kill my
my cousin and my uncle
and
i became a little more recursive about
it a little more strong and pushing back
and
pushed away from everybody in the family
and
became relentless um
i think my sister ted was the first one
to pick up on it tabitha
and
she started realizing something was
wrong but
um
never really wanting to
to talk about it because you know
i thought nobody would believe me anyway
or that i would get in trouble because
you know i was a kid i was a liar and i
did what i wanted to do and
i thought if i ever was honest about
anything or things coming together that
people would jump on me for it
um
so you know i sort of ran away from home
a couple times
moved away
and then when i became
[Music]
after my 15th birthday i um
my mom and dad had broken up and i was
living with my dad at the time
and
won
the house in long beach on passing the
19th um
i lived there i went to school and doing
everything like normal and i would sneak
guys in and hang back and chill and
sneak girls in
and then
to make up for the faction of being a
gay man i had kids um many many many
kids actually
um
i met with girls and
got girls pregnant on purpose just so
that
um my brothers
which i found out later and my sisters
and mom and dad would never know about
what was going on
you know life was crazy
[Music]
so
i was
i had an appeal started working out
getting buffer um
then i started getting more into the
gang life
and um
started getting in trouble starting to
get arrested
doing time
and then while i was busted i would meet
sally's who
you know after we took a shower together
they see me naked um get interested
and then i started switching sales with
people and
hooking up and
enjoying being incarcerated actually
um
i had officers and nurses and teachers
and stuff as well there were guys and
girls
who um
would give me you know searches and
seizures and check my body out and
see that i was pretty blessed and
get curious enough to want to do
something and so i started having sex
with guys girls and workers and staff
and cops and
to get approval to get away
um my
mom and dad whenever i got in trouble in
jail or would cut me away um
because they didn't want to support the
habit that i was going through
my sisters
when i come home were real cool and
close with me but when i was locked up
they would
not showing the approval to it you know
i wouldn't get any letters or writings
or visits or anything like that so kind
of the tough lift thing
so i got more life into the game life
and more into the homeboys and
more into doing crimes and selling cars
and robbing people and fights and
assaults and stabbings and still works
i was blessed to never get caught for
the violent charges but you know i would
steal cars and your car was still in
cars and
um
a few assault charges and things like
that
than me being
stupid and reckless growing up in life
[Music]
i
became a police explorer for the city of
long beach
as a junior cop
and
i did it to understand the concept of
how the cops were gonna come and search
the neighborhood for the gang life
i
got real good at it actually so whenever
they were gonna do neighborhood searches
for what was going on what was going to
happen i would tell the homeboys to you
know to take a lie down to stop doing
what they were doing because they were
going to do searches and
you know life moved on
um
i ended up getting
caught in the process of being an active
game in berlin i got kicked out of the
police explorers so i got more involved
in the gang life
then i started doing more time i started
getting more violent and started getting
more fights and more assault charges and
more stealing cars and
i was so good at stealing cars i could
rob any car that came in contact with me
and
i was so good at it that i would drive
the cars and keep them for a while
before i would take them away
and
pick my homeboys up and get them where
they need to go and move on and
do that for about three four five six
months and then get caught in the car
do 16 months
three years
come out do it all over again
and
my family looked at me like they never
understood what was happening
i was being rebellious because you know
it's being molested and nobody would
believe me so
and i would never tell my sisters or
anything because
they weren't closed like that and as i
started getting older they see me acting
reckless they started pushing away from
me
um i didn't actually get closer to them
until i became older
um
dropped out of high school because i was
incarceration during our
uh graduation time got my ged while i
was you know on parole
um
got out went to college went to westwood
colorado technology for computer
programming
um
got my associate's degree
then i got locked up again
um
while i was incarcerated i went to
coastline college and got a bachelor's
degree in business management
[Music]
moved out and lived life
in the whole process of everything
happening to me you know keeping a total
secret going on i was with a
um
my ex fiance who was a guy um edwin
and we were together from 96
um
to
about maybe four or five months ago we
broke up in between i mean
he cheated on me a couple times with
people and um
i split up and go get with other guys
move on
um
live life like normal
during the time while this happening i
would go to a gay church
in um
long beach
on temple
10th
and became real cool and calm and
collected with the people there and i
met um jim
a guy who had a huge crush on me
and found out in the time of me doing my
life that
for work i
was the only high school kid who was
still doing nude modeling and exotic
dancing
so i was
16 17
dancing in gay clubs
and because of my size and the body that
i had at that time they never carded me
or asked me questions about my age or
anything so
i was making money living life and doing
what i had to do
um
life was perfect and it seemed
well during the time of that happening i
met some kid
named sean um he had a huge crush on me
as well he was one of jim's friends
and jim told me to go help the family
out because he know me being a gang
member and being a fighter that shawn
needed help so i went and met sean and
met this kid hangbuck and children
he told me that his mom's boyfriend was
molesting him
so
me trying to be captain savage
i ran up and
got really close to sean and his family
and ended up meeting this guy he was
molesting his um messy melissa and sean
and
went and got a couple of homeboys and we
took the guy out and handled the
situation you know made sure it stopped
i thought everything was cool and
everything was normal and everything was
done
um
but
sean was in a foster care home and his
grandmother um lived in idaho
springfield actually and she would fly
in on the weekends and pick him up
and then get a hotel until six
and for
um friday saturday and sunday we would
stay in the motel
uh hang back and chill and drink and
relax
and live like normal and i like going
there because you know i was being
spoiled as a kid and i got whatever i
wanted
um this happened for years
and then um
by the time i turned
so let's see
now i'm 39
seven years ago
i was 32
four years before that so from the age
of 28
i i met the family hanging back and
children
and i would go back and mean sean's
grandmother would sit back and get drunk
and hang back and chill together and
drink
and
we'd get pretty wasted and turn out um
shawn would wait so i went to sleep and
would come in and you know you know
sean's only like 14 15 at the time would
slide his hands up and
um
try to get me aroused and i woke up a
few nights with him sucking my dick or
trying to sit on top of me
and now
i pushed him off and told him relax and
you know he's too young and when he gets
18 we'll talk about his age you know
hooking up but
i wouldn't do it to his 18
and
kind of pushing back and doing
everything like normal
well during the time of this happening
his grandmother also had a huge crush on
me and she knew that i was a stripper
and a model and they would come to
long beach in la and hollywood where i
was stripped in the clubs
circus arena temple
um
fire island executive suites for um
a few other clubs and would come help me
and support me and they can chill
and so things were as they were and
i started using my body to get what i
wanted
um escorted for a while
um
then i got
a little more smart about my aspects of
life and
got sugar daddies and sugar mamas would
come down
and as much as they got to see me naked
and suck my dick or to play around with
me they would pay me money to hang back
and chill
so um i i did what i had to do and
survived
i moved out got different boyfriends and
started paying rent and living life like
normal
um life was going cool life was going
perfect and
i would still on the weekends they would
um shawn and his grandmother come pick
me up and we would go back to the hotel
and i can chill and go out to movies and
shopping and sprays and things like that
and then drink and go home and
every once in a while shawn would come
in and
hop in the bed with me and
want to do stuff and i would wake up and
push him away and tell him to relax and
move on then to make sure it stopped
happening i started bringing my
boyfriends with me when i started going
over to the houses to hang back and
chill with them to ensure that nothing
would happen
and things are going perfect and cool
and the days that i didn't bring my
boyfriends with me
are the days that we were drinking
harder than normal um sean would do it
again and
you know it is what it is um
then sean found out that his grandmother
had got drunk with me
and she did it she started sucking my
day again
wanting to have sex
and
i got arrested for eight months in
county jail
and i was gone for a while and when i
finally came back
um
sean grandmother had told sean about
that her and i had headed
an encounter of her
sucking my dick and going off
and that i didn't stop her
and sean got mad
i guess that i didn't do anything with
him but i was willing to do something
with his grandmother
so he waited for her to
call me to invite me to mental six
and i went to motel 6
and hung back and showed like normally
and we started drinking hanging back and
then there was a knock on the door
and then sean told me to go over the
door
so i got up and opened the door and
there's two cops sitting there
and they go you tie and i go yeah and
then go do you know sean blakeman i go
yeah he's right there
and they
told him to come over and they asked me
is this the guy
and sean said yeah
and i go am i the guy what
the officer told me this is
um this is the guy that you're the guy
that sean said has been molesting him
since the age of 15. and at this time
john he was
17
um about 17 and a half six months from
2018
and um they told me my own probation
proletarizing parole and told me cool
turned around they cuffed me
and
put sex trans structures on me
um
my god um
it was harder um
i'm in orange county
a caucasian neighborhood
caucasian community come here caucasian
court caucasian d.a
caucasian judge
and i'm a black man
with an asian attorney
and the d.a
and the side chambers laughed at us and
told us i don't even have to fight this
case you guys are not going to win here
so you might as well take a deal
so i went to court and
they told me that if i was found guilty
that um
sean would um
step up in court and give a convincing
story and they were going to try to give
me 127 years of life
um
fearful of all is happening and this is
at the same time that um
what's his name bill cosby was fighting
his
case so you know a dark seeing person
looking in court didn't look good no
matter what happened anyway and they
weren't believing anything else being
said anyway and i didn't want to catch
life in prison for something that i
didn't do
i mean i i can't lie he
when me being asleep or happening like
that i would wake up to feeling
something stuck on my dick and you know
felt good and
still being out of tune or you know out
of it i let it happen for a while and
then i would wake up and realize it was
him and push him off and how incident
would happen and
i always never would ever tell on him
though i would always feel bad for him
because i knew how he felt i'm being
molested and i know that
the being molested you tend to get used
to the features and you fall into the
lifestyle that's how i became a gay man
um
i mean
that added to the fact of having so many
kids
um
moved on and live life
how many years did you do so for the
case i took a deal for 10 years with 85
i did seven years
and six months
um
i just got out may 1st actually
so i have been down for seven years and
six months before that for me first
went to every rough yard
got tired of the life the gang life i
got jumped out of my gang while i was in
prison
um
they found out that i was gay
even though
i was having sex with a few of my
homeboys from the hood
um
everybody had to put on a big macho act
to kind of not get in a victim position
and
i was jumped by
15 homies from my hood
and 15 homeboys that were in the in the
unit
so 30 people jumping um
they cut my throat
they sliced the back of my head
i got stabbed six seven times
um
they put me in a coma for nine and a
half months
um
it
it took me a year and after another walk
again
um i was in a wheelchair
um
thank god the first time that my mom and
dad came to visit me and my sisters
was when i was in the hospital
um
i went from
172 pounds um
17 half inch arms dude i was the most
amazing looking person possible
and when i woke up from a coma i was 100
and
19 120 pounds
um
intravenously that's how i was being fed
um
my god it took
everything
um
my greatest achievement at the time was
just being able to stand up on my own um
to use the bathroom ticker piss
um they took a catheter they had the
catheter in me the whole time that was
in a coma and they took it out and god
that was a reckless feeling
um
um
i couldn't testify on my homeboys or
telling anybody because
i'm being
mauled
um
and had the [ __ ] beat out of me um
i don't remember faces or what happening
it's funny now that
it's been
you know
maybe 12 years from happening um
i can now visually see faces of what
happened i remember the first guy who
hit me i remember i knocked out two of
the guys i remember the first guy who
pulled a blade out and slit my throat i
can take a pencil and now each other
faces
um
i remember everything about everything
now
and it took years for it to happen and
all this happened in 2005.
so um
i walk with a cane moving around
um because my stability for walking is
still shaky
um
[Music]
i have
terrible seizures
bad bad seizures and i don't know when
they're coming
um just in the program that i'm now not
i'll still be living home because my pro
officer put me in this program to help
me get over my anger issues
i don't do drugs i don't drink
i mean i train peers when i play cool or
something like that but i don't get
involved in anything like that i
don't have the issues with drugs or
drinking no inclination to use it to
fall or to use their physical and escape
guilty or feelings or emotions
um
so i
push away from my poll officer because
um
i feel like she has something against me
um but you know
i wanted to do any and everything to
stay out of trouble
i'm gonna stick with this pearl officer
because
i got out and have to register as a sex
offender
i have an ankle monitor on and
i have to go through courses and classes
and meetings and groups
about something that has no feelings or
emotions for me i don't have any thought
practices when kids walk by or anything
like that i can care less about them
um
give me a cute older guy
or a gorgeous sexy girl who just you
know who's wild and exotic and [ __ ] i'm
on
uh
did it kick you by me dude
immediately i see myself as a kid and i
recall everything that happened to me
vividly and i can relive it over and
over and over again and
um
it's nerve-wracking actually
i can
picture myself screaming
you know being a 15 14 year old kid
growing up having a
a family member
who was like over 10 inches right knee
and
kind of get through it and not telling
anybody because nobody believed me
anyway
and
i bled a few times and
got over it then my cousin um
alton
as i got older
um
i lived on my own he came down to long
beach and met up with me
and
got curious enough to fall from my dick
instead of my ass
and
um
going through what my mom and dad taught
me learning to forgive and move on i
forgave him and
being stupid i had sex with him and
then i moved away
just couldn't deal with it anymore
never ever told i'm pretty sure my
family my sisters and some are probably
watching are going to see this and
probably be enlightened by all this i
never told anybody
i
i felt ashamed i felt shared scared
i swore nobody would ever believe me um
i figured they thought that i would
use it as an excuse for why i became
i took it to guys
and not just man up and just say that i
was always you know into dudes um
i don't know
i don't know i listen to other
psychiatrists and all this [ __ ]
happening and
everybody talks about like you're gay
because you're born that way and
i don't think so i
i think the actions of what happened to
me
and
going through it so much and not and
having to shut the [ __ ] up and keep it
to myself and take it and then taking it
so much enjoying it and enjoying it so
much jumping out to the effect of
actually using it to get what i wanted
to get in life
is what more to me to become a gay man
and then after doing it for so [ __ ]
long
um
things are where they are
and
life is audience
and then
i have my facebook pages and my modeling
accounts and my modeling companies i own
the ceo of a modeling agency as ceo of a
ship company and i have dancers that
work in all through california
i have a couple models that work in the
philippines
a couple in thailand
one in the uk
two in cuba one in colombia
two in australia
a couple in idaho new york
and
we work out i have a site that i pay and
put together to help promote us and keep
us going and
i modeled for so long and i was so great
attractive to it that i expressed life
as it was
and i never got
became ashamed of who i was what i was
about
after being
dominated so much as a kid that
i took advantage of my weaknesses and
became
the teasing figure that most people know
me to be today
and
i get in the company and
i meet david um
and
david tells me
he lets me watch his video
and
he when i become best friends because i
feel like his whole story is my story i
feel like his shadow i'm the darker
version of him
you know only difference between us is
that baby stays straight and
i turn gay
but we're best friends and hang back and
chill
but because of our lifestyles we're
stuck in the same program and that's
where we're living home
and we start to dictate to pearl
officers
that were psyched addicts and that we
have to go through this course and they
still worry about
us being around kids and we have no
feelings or emotions toward them anyway
but you know
society or
the government or groups don't
really give a [ __ ] on what you think or
care
think about who you are as a person what
your record says
so i meet everybody and everybody knows
me and on facebook i'm loved
i
go from
i think
50 friends before i get arrested
and have my family keep posting pictures
and votes on me and things like that and
i get back out and now i think i have
like
almost like 2 000 buddies on my buddies
now and everybody hits me because i post
my pictures and my facebook page has got
half undressed pictures of me showing my
bulge in my ass and my great [ __ ]
body and the teasing sensation to me
dancing in clubs and getting into it and
the support i have for my family
and
i don't
i know my sister my sister toyah
um
the one i end up meeting later in life
um
at the age of
16 17 i finally meet my birth brothers i
find out that i have
um my brother uh roselle
um julius
um eddie uh who we call snoopy and
reggie who i've never met but um
i find out i have boys in my family now
and
i don't know how to explain or talk to
them like
i didn't grow up with boys so i grew up
with girls
and my sisters had
[ __ ] all attractive boyfriends
and they were cute but
i didn't like their attitudes so i would
sneak off and go get with my own guys
and stick with a couple girls and
live life and
try to jump back and forth
and
the funny thing is um
sean at the time the guy who accused me
for molesting him was trying to be a
police explorer too a sheriff explorer
so
i would tell him all my life and i told
him about me being molested and things
happening to me so i think i helped
encourage him to
use
his tools as a
sheriff explorer
to convict me of what was going on so i
mean i
take blaming it
it's hard i cry
um
cried for years
i cried so much that i
i
i i don't worry about the tears you know
uh
i've learned to hide them back
[ __ ] inside i feel broken
um
i can't go to holidays or
events or
i can't do anything because of my ankle
monitor
and i had club owners who were willing
to
because they were so in love with my
dancing abilities and my
presentation with clientele and how his
clients came into me
i was a kid and
on an average night on a bad night i
would walk home with
anywhere from
six to nine thousand dollars in tips
i had bags i would come and book it
loads on my facebook page i have
buckets of money that i would make
and i would do private parties in
people's houses guys and girls or mix
parties
and then i realized that i was so good
at guys and girls that i became a
swinger
and i kept girlfriends who were so into
my body and they loved the fact of
watching me [ __ ] guys
or
suck dick or lick ass
and they loved the passion that i had
and how i was a thug when it came to
being protective of them and i was a
fighter and i'll protect anybody i care
for
and if you cross anybody that i'm really
cool with i'll come and get you
my mentality
so i believe
my pro officer put me in this sober
living home to help me get over my
addiction of anger
and
at least i hope so
and not
being bitter towards me
but
i'm using it to
learn the 12 steps of alcohol and drugs
and any symptoms and i'm getting the
best pieces out of it to get over my
attitude issues
and it's hard
been in a house full of drug addicts and
ex-drug addicts and ex-drinkers and
their [ __ ] up allergies and [ __ ] up
thought processes and their [ __ ] up
moods because they don't have a drink or
they're not high at that moment and then
waking up on the wrong [ __ ] side of
the bed
and then snapping at you because you're
the only sore [ __ ] in the whole
house
and then they say something because i'm
still new and they're not aware of the
fact that if i want to act stupid and
dumb and [ __ ] want to fight dude i
already know i'm going to get life in
prison so [ __ ] why stop you mean why
be a kind cat and if i'm going to get
locked up regardless and my pro officer
looks for any and every [ __ ] reason
to lock me up
it's like it is what it is
i i have the love and loyalty of the
staff there
and the guys how things move there
what's what's the most important thing
you've learned in all of this it's a
hell of a story
of a life you live
i trust my first feelings
um i've learned boundaries
if i don't fit with you
if you're [ __ ] up and i don't like
how you feel dude i'll cut you off
completely
i was such a person to always please
everybody to keep everybody close to me
i don't give a [ __ ] about that anymore
if i'm cool with you and everything goes
to it i'll bend over backwards for you
i've got your back and i'll do
everything for you
if there's something about you that's
wrong dude i don't want you [ __ ] near
me and i don't care anything about you
and i love you to death and i'll pray
for you and i'll keep
my mind and ears and i'll open for you
hope the best for you but i don't want
to deal with you i've been with enough
[ __ ] already
and i don't want to go back to it
and i don't want it around me
and i've done i'm 39 years old and i've
done
over 23 years in prison
i did a 15-year term
my god i [ __ ] grew up in prison
it's [ __ ] sad
i met my mom my birth mother
we have issues um
i forgave her for giving me up
um
my mom my adopted mom effie taught me
well
she made me the man i am today
she taught me
so many hirings
remarkable integrity
and i have sisters who
even do my [ __ ] ups are still there for
me
my adopted sisters and my birth sister
latoya
um who we call toyah um
all of us like
will always be there for me will always
give me an ear if i ever need to call
them and talk to them and then i'm going
through something
life is always there for me
in the silver living home that i'm
living in at now yesterday we had a
drive by
during one of our meetings or meetings
and the day before
one of our other group meetings it was
another drive-by
and
it's so [ __ ] reckless and stupid the
guys in my company
in the program
instead of being smart and jumping on
the floor like a smart person would
[ __ ] do these guys go outside
open the door and go back and chill and
want to look around and i'm like the
[ __ ] are you doing like
is this your first time
but yeah
you live and learn eh i'm gonna save
myself
and everybody around me that i [ __ ]
really hold dear
there are many people in the program
that i love to death
um
i'm the dumb super kid i
before i got into the program i had
money in the bank
and
i still paid rent on the houses and
my car and
looking for work and
getting back into it and after the 90
day blackout period um
i'm a manager for
my phone you know the company that gives
off free phones and tablets to people
i'm one of the managers for the company
at top
and
they're waiting for me to get off the
90-day app so i can get back into work
and then php people helping people a
brokerage firm
um
seeing my indeed account and what i go
through
and talk to me had a cool interview and
things going back and forth and
or even with me as i got incarcerated
and came back and
they're willing to do every and
everything for me to help me out
never right when i you know posted the
fact there was a drive by my family and
you know at the house and everybody's
texting me like are you safe is
everything cool and i'm like yeah i'm
used to this [ __ ]
i grew up in a gay neighborhood this is
nothing for me but
um
i don't know if
i'm able to say um
i understand there
are a lot of people who get hit with
charges like me who didn't do anything
wrong
i mean there are some [ __ ] up people
that put us in weird awkward positions
but then there are a lot of us with
these bands on there who are really
[ __ ] up and sticking stupid and did
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it's hard being around people like
that
and
while being incarcerated there's many of
them i wanted to [ __ ] walk left and
right
like [ __ ] had sex with [ __ ] four
or five-year-old kids
and they were cool with it i wanted to
talk about it and talk back and forth
and share pictures and
couldn't stand these [ __ ]
then i feel like i'm there like [ __ ]
here i'm here for a [ __ ] bogus charge
but i'm stuck with all this [ __ ]
and this is a lifetime thing
and i don't know what's going to happen
but i thank god that
who i was as a person in
my ambitions and my goals and my jobs
and going to schools and degrees and
stuff that i got
make me a remarkable person
to companies
i have a three-page resume that's
[ __ ] impeccable
i have teachers and jobs and colleges
that are still willing to to write for
me and people that are listening to
trust me even with my monitor on me and
everybody knows everything
i'm not a person to hide it if you want
to nobody i'll tell you about it tell
you about the case take about my charges
say i got a band on say that i can't
visit people's houses
i can't get a sexual [ __ ] energy i'm
going to hang back and chill with
anybody because i can't visit properties
and if i go to somebody's house i might
get violated and my problem should look
for any reason to lock myself
so i don't want to get into it but you
know [ __ ] happens
but i hook up with anybody in my program
nah
i have no ambitions or goals to undergo
people that do drugs and stuff like that
i never got into it before i don't plan
to start now
but
um
i want to see
a new start
um
i'm thankful
for all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've gone
through it's given me experience to
learn to try to help somebody who's
going through similar mistakes and give
them advice on what to do and what not
to do so they don't end up in a position
like mine
so don't get stuck with it
if i had somebody to tell me how i i'm
talking right now i was able to watch a
video like this
[ __ ] life would be so grand for me
right now
i would be [ __ ] running for [ __ ]
mayor or something for some city
i would have [ __ ] moved a long time
ago i would live life perfectly
i would be in puerto rico right now
helping me build everything back up to
[ __ ] get everything going back to
life
i would be chilling
i would be [ __ ] probably married to a
girl having a boyfriend on the side
and enjoying every bit of it
i would be [ __ ]
an amazing man i love how even through
what i'm going through even through my
time even through my charges
my birth kids still [ __ ] want to
contact me even though their mothers are
mad that i'm with guys
they want to be with me that my kids
still want to [ __ ] figure out who i
am
my kids are 18 19 and [ __ ] living
life and
i had my first kid when i was 14.
i had twins when i was 15
and had triplets when i turned 18.
and then more kids beyond that
[ __ ]
11 kids
i had 12 but my son died when i was
incarcerated in a car crash
but um
it's another pain another story
um
for anybody like me that has a case
you're stuck with a [ __ ] band on you
don't give up
life isn't over
[Music]
seek strive become better
don't make any similar mistakes
be on your ps and keys watch your ass
everybody's watching you
whether you think it or not everybody's
on you they're gonna watch you to make
any mistake and they're gonna send your
ass back
and if you're [ __ ] stupid enough to
make the same mistakes
my
my [ __ ] wish you just go lock
yourself up spend the rest of your life
in there enjoy yourself yeah more fun in
prison than you would out here anyway
before you [ __ ] i want to live
life and become better strive
seek life man
if you're a kid you're being touched or
molested by somebody say something
put their asses on blast stop that [ __ ]
short
don't
be reclusive don't lock it up
say something
it will make you a better person
use what you've learned what you've gone
through and be better for somebody
younger so that the kids today don't
think about the [ __ ] that we went
through as the younger kids
their lives were
it was okay to do something like that as
long as it was quiet and kept secret or
they threatened you with [ __ ] your
life or taking [ __ ] from you it's not
worth it
be better man
everybody be stronger
live life
it's unfortunate that that kid uh did
that to you you do all that time
you know what the funniest part is
um
he [ __ ] when i get out he contacts me
when you got out yeah after he got out i
mean
i
recklessly put my number on facebook and
everybody still contacts me you know for
my modeling account he calls me
and um
from a black number a smart little kid
and he tells me that he's sorry
and then he feels bad for what happened
and that if he could relive life he
would have never put me in a position
that he put me in
and that now that he's older that he's
waiting for
and hopefully willing that he can meet
up with me to
actually experience fully what it feels
like being with me after i'm seeing all
my pictures and stuff like that
and that he's glad that
he's older now he can accept it
and that he's
bigger and more mature enough to take my
size and enjoy every bit of it now
and i was like
you [ __ ] serious dog like
you had the audacity to [ __ ] have me
threatened with 147 years of life in
prison
and you [ __ ] jump up with it and go
through all that [ __ ]
and then you get up and you grow older
and you realize how [ __ ] worthless of
a person you are
and then you call
to apologize
because you thought the old forgiving me
is gonna give a [ __ ] about it today
[ __ ] you know what president did
to me prison taught me to hate people
around me
i don't trust anybody
there's an ambition to tie everything
you have to be
a completely amazing person for me to be
close to you now
if i don't see it i don't care for you
[Music]
that's all i got to say man
very tight
thank you so much
very interesting
thank you
you